[Music]
all right Anheuser-Busch still reeling
from its folks stunt promoting Bud Light
with trans uh gender activist Dylan
Mulvaney on Friday the Anheuser-Busch
hair Billy Bush not to be well confused
with the journalist had some harsh words
for the company amid the seemingly
endless Fallout take a look
I think my family my ancestors would
have rolling over in their grave they
were very patriotic they loved this
country and what it stood for they
believed that transgender
um gays that sort of thing was all a
very personal issue
um they love this country because it is
a free country and people are allowed to
do what they want but it was never meant
to be on a beer can and never meant to
be pushing people's faces
joining us now is the author of family
Reigns Billy bush is with us well by the
way what a great legacy for you and and
you know your you know your family's
background is pretty incredible the
story of success the American dream
personified
um why would they be rolling over in
their grave you know delve a little
deeper into that
I think that
um you know they first of all wouldn't
have ever gotten as political as this
and let's face it the transgender uh
topic today has become very
very political and it's not wise for a
beer company to get into that into that
game I think that it's difficult
um enough to to to be
um advertising beer and to try to do it
um when and be political about it I
think it's uh it's just not the way to
go but you know my fear from the very
beginning and at one point I got some
people mad at me because I said I don't
want this to go on very long I'm hoping
the company will straighten it out I
thought the the best thing they could do
is apologize for getting into the
political Arena we made a mistake we're
sorry
um I think that might have gone a long
way at that time to help them I don't
know if it would work now it would seem
like an act of desperation but my fear
was that you know the guys that work in
the brewery and and the factories and
that drive the trucks they're the one
paying they're the ones paying the price
they're now losing career jobs over this
they are paying the price and I think
the the company greatly miscalculated uh
what what they thought
um was being inclusive but it really was
divisive I think my family was they they
lived by the model making friends as our
business and they believed that bringing
people together making it a sociable fun
uh beer drinking experience was the way
to go
um but you know people that drink Bud
Light the drink beer
um really don't relate to that kind of
advertising and um so it was it was a
huge mistake
so let me ask you do you have any
influence any connection to the
management the current management
and if you don't and you had an
opportunity to talk to them what would
you tell them
if I had an opportunity to talk to them
first of all no I don't have any
relationship or any um any management uh
connection any any kind of management
decision making that they're there but
if I had a chance to talk to them I'd
say really understand who your Beer
Drinker is and who um your audience is
with uh with your Brands because
um you know trying to push us a
political agenda
um in such a way
um obviously is not the way to go
because you can tell because it's hurt
sales so much and sales have dropped
have plummeted so uh you know really
take the time to get out there uh learn
about
um America this is a foreign company
learn what you know what sells in
America
um understand what the beer business is
like and sell to those people in that
way
all right Billy Bush uh it's sad I hope
and by the way you know it was
benefiting the Molson chorus and Miller
Lite they're all benefiting Coors Light
Miller Lite you know their sales are
through the roof uh at anheuser-busch's
expense appreciate you being with us I'm
Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm
Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis